[Music]
you know it's funny I was watching the
the Screen Actors Guild Awards last
night and and you guys had one of the
funniest moments which is yeah we tried
to brighten it up telling I mean we made
it up let's be honest but we said that
we made up this drinking game on
bridesmaids because we were trying to
loosen up the room you know yeah so you
can you you guys said we said that we we
have a drinking game that whenever
someone says a word this particular word
you drink and the word was Scorsese
right which by the way is the correct
pronunciation I did I did investigative
research very nice cuz I've been things
course AZ like all of us American one
dummies and and it's Scorsese it's
Scorsese yes so yeah all right so I made
a we did it and on the show and I didn't
know Mike my kids were watching last
night and this morning my six-year-old
came in for school and she said mama I
said and then took a shot did you guys
did you meet anyone exciting last night
I would think I mean I met Brad and
Angelina you met them I mean that's
exciting
yes yes yes they are the two most eerily
attractive people I mean we meet
everybody and then you see those two in
there it's like they're from another
planet there's light coming off that
faces a glow they glow in the night then
you get like a Viper
i lock stare and you're like I will do
whatever you want yeah so what was it
like were you nervous to actually really
nice they really love bridesmaids and
they said that they have the movie and
they've watched it about shows which was
so nice and we were talking about it and
everything and I realized I was being
like ultra cool when I was talking to
Mike yeah oh that's great thanks thanks
be like I realized that when I get
nervous I get super like relax you
overcompensate
I totally overcompensate it I was like
oh guys it's so good to see I've never
met them before and then they're huge
stars yeah I think it's like one of
those things like your body goes into
fear mode like when you're gonna get
eaten by a bear
like you just have to relax and let the
bear put you in its mouth I want to hear
you talk to a bear about you mention
here you mentioned your kids you you
have two girls and then a son Jack is
six months old
okay so this is your first boy and are
you now being made aware of what a huge
difference there is between oh my god
light years difference right yeah like I
have a girl and that who's eight and
then I have a boy who's six and it's
everything you've ever heard it's true
yeah like when when my oldest started
preschool I noticed you know like when
the girls were social and they'd say you
know lastly wouldn't wouldn't play with
me today and she said my hair looked
funny and I still watch guys talk about
okay and then the boy come to me like ah
somebody yeah but my son is I can see
the difference like he's he's almost
slug-like like he's sort of like he's
super cute he's really young we got to
give him that
first of all six months cloud chicken
come on his legs don't move that well
his reading skills are birth he thought
boring yeah
we're talking about a six-month-old well
I'm waiting for him to make me but it is
true even later on like you would you'll
see it does hold true that my daughter
who's eight is always flipping through a
New Yorker and saying well I disagree
and my sons in the corner like pushing
fire into the wall antique things things
with face